a sign of hope for a half Muhammad al
kanoon these pictures show the young
Saudi woman leaving the airport in
Bangkok together with officials from the
UN refugee agency the UNHCR will assess
whether she can be granted refugee
status protecting her from deportation
this marks a pause in a tense standoff
that began on Saturday our kanoon
arrived from Saudi Arabia but had her
passport seized by a Saudi diplomat
initially Thailand said it would deport
her because she didn't meet visa
requirements the 18 year old then
barricaded herself in an airport hotel
room she drew attention to her plight on
social media quickly gathering tens of
thousands of followers
she said she feared for her life after
her family threatened her for renouncing
Islam and cutting her hair UNHCR I want
the Thai authorities seemed to perform a
dramatic about-face then promising not
to deport her we will talk to her and do
whatever she requests she escaped
trouble to seek our help and we are the
Land of Smiles we will not send anyone
to their death we won't do that
we will adhere to human rights and
principles under the rules Thailand is
not a signatory to the UN Refugee
Convention and provides no legal
protection to asylum seekers but the
United Nations says it will do
everything in its power to help Alka
noon
well I'm joined tonight here at the big
table by Vento makovski he is the
director of the German office of Human
Rights Watch it's good to have you back
on the show I mean we just heard there
Thailand is not obligated really to any
human rights treaty they would have been
doing the legal thing had they followed
the requests made by the Saudi
government that's what they would have
argued would you say then that this
woman tonight the fact that she is still
in Thailand that she is a very lucky
woman she's a very lucky woman because
of the media attention the world is
looking so I can't believe that Thailand
now will let her go back to Kuwait or
Saudi Arabia but she's not absolutely
safe so who knows yeah I mean it's like
we said her future is still uncertain I
want you to take a listen to what the UN
High Commissioner for Human Rights said
today about dealing with Thailand in
this case take a listen but we have a
strongly advocated with the Thai
government and we have received
assurances that pending the completion
of the assessment and any decision she
would not be sent back because that
would be a case of racial monk and the
word person of freedom could
so that was the first priority and
I'm here was it as simple he makes it
sound like he was as simple as a
consultation with Thailand and then the
decision was made not to send her back
but would Thailand have cooperated if
there had been no no Twitter if there
had been their public awareness if there
had been no immediate attention it's a
special Asian but I think that the media
attention absolutely helped we've seen
that recently in the case of a soccer
player the Bahraini soccer player who is
still in danger of being deported back
to Iran where he would face probably
imprisonment maybe even torture so the
Thailand is not to be trusted in this
because they're not signatory to the UN
Refugee guidelines and obligations and
Thailand itself is the military
dictatorship so there's a big problem I
mean the head of Thailand's immigration
bureau said earlier today
if deporting her would result in her
death we definitely would not want to do
that I mean do you believe him well you
know it's a what what you can't what can
he say now but yeah the thing is what
does it mean even if if Thailand gets
guarantees that she won't be killed just
imprisoned forever or sent back to her
family and be abused there and
mistreated and confined to her golden
cage to her home and the problem is that
women in Saudi Arabia are not free
they're not even treated as adults also
they're over 18 she's 18 yes she's an
adult she should be able to travel as
she likes
according to Saudi law women are always
treated as - they're legally - children
mm-hmm and so no wonder she wanted to
run away what about this and the timing
following the murder of the journalist
Jamal khashoggi Saudi Arabia in the eyes
of many in the world is a a country a
regime
a royal family that has yeah maybe has
committed murder with impunity do you
see it now with having a tendency to go
after say cases like this anywhere in
the world and bring these women home or
go after people who are critical of the
government I hope so because months ago
before the killing of Khashoggi we had a
very similar case of the Philippines
returning a Saudi woman to her family
and we haven't heard from her since
nobody knows where she is she's back in
Saudi Arabia but how is she
she has disappeared there's no way to
confirm it but now the Khashoggi case
has finally opened many people's eyes to
the realities in Saudi Arabia before a
lot was whitewashed lots of people
bought into the propaganda of the prince
and people said oh there's so much
progress now women can drive cars and
not seeing that those women who were
fighting for the right to drive landed
in prison but but but many would argue
that Saudi Arabia has not been punished
or has not been taken to task for what
happened with Jamal khashoggi and they
would say that Riyadh
feels emboldened by that and that it
thinks that it can get away with even
more cases that you and I would find
egregious and maybe even illegal I mean
do you think that the royal the crown
prince of the royal family do you think
that they are becoming more aggressive
in pursuing people you know like her
well the danger is really there as long
as there is impunity that's why Human
Rights Watch is calling for an
independent international inquiry into
this case and we're urging turkey to ask
the young general secretary to implement
such a independent inquiry and before we
run out of time if there were to be an
inquiry and if there were to be negative
consequences for Saudi Arabia what do
you think that would mean then for the
women inside the country do you think
for example
social media in the country would be
shut down because that's what may have
saved your life today well first of all
social media in the country is shut down
so she was able to tweet the broad in
Thailand and you know building even
greater firewalls is what I'm talking
about do you see that well I think I
think if there is ongoing impunity then
we won't have any improvement if there's
an international punishment then Saudi
Arabia will have one day to lose in its
very strict rules yeah The Guardian the
may guardianship for women and and all
these terrible things that's going on
there in cell makovski director of the
German office of Human Rights Watch as
always we appreciate you coming on the
show and sharing your insights thank you